[Music]
have you guys seen
this [ __ ] these robot dogs i know you
have seen these where like you can kick
these these robots and they'll like
correct their oh yeah yeah oh yeah other
than the boston dynamic ones yeah yeah
so that was a couple years ago right
well now they have other ones they have
like these robot dogs that's so scary
why do they look like black mirror and
[ __ ]
i'm not down to see that [ __ ] on the
streets yet no way bro oh my god they
need to make it cuddly dude
and like yeah if you break it like it
looks too much like a bug is it like
destruction of public property is that
what happened
my property i don't [ __ ] know what do
you mean while driving and [ __ ] first
of all this edit they need two of them
in there to make it feel all weird
oh yeah
all right yeah it makes me feel weird
i'd have to double up the video and make
it feel awkward
damn that [ __ ] looks like a bug
wait so like who's who's running it that
is not a dog that's a cricket and what
do they hope to achieve with that scare
people scare the [ __ ] yeah that's what
it is surveillance maybe the plan is for
military use
of course black mirror dude just blast
that thing
but what if that thing blasts you i know
oh you know what you do you just pour
water on it it's all good that's it
electrocute that won't work in the rain
you don't work in the rain no [ __ ]
way though one of the newest things that
they're doing it's nice
don't you feel like you're gonna have
like a robot go around they might as
well do like street sweeping hitting
them with [ __ ] guns dude oh
[ __ ]
yeah okay
they're like bugs with guns honestly
that's sick as [ __ ] though it is this is
the iron man movie bro that [ __ ] looks
like things i would [ __ ] draw in
elementary yeah that's some stark
industry [ __ ] yeah being pissed getting
shot by a [ __ ] dog
thumbs and you [ __ ] shot me
100
yeah you better [ __ ] shoot me with
your [ __ ] hands bro yeah
you better
so people are getting freaked out
because you know they were already scary
enough before but now it's like
yeah now you got a gun on man you put
guns on these [ __ ] what
authorizes it to shoot though because
maybe it won't have human air maybe it's
not ai maybe it's a like robot like
somebody's like a drone like a land
drone a land drone yeah yeah if it's
like a land drone [ __ ] it motion sensors
oh my god that's right that's what it is
anything you move rather than dude
doesn't
that gets killed that's true what freaks
me out about this [ __ ] though like if
you if i told a member of the military
to do something [ __ ] up go in that
home shoot those civilians or something
there's a chance that they're like i'm
not gonna [ __ ] do this [ __ ] even if
even with orders and all that kind of
stuff there's like humanity still it's
like your own personal morality that
that doesn't exist here but that's what
i'm saying is it ai operated or is it
like uh like a drone like someone's
operating currently there's someone
operating but they are but they do have
ai like the one you just saw that was
walking around was ai
wow
we i don't want a [ __ ]
robot with a gun that has a mind of its
own that's [ __ ] scary
well if we do have them i hope it's just
in our country you know what i'm saying
and they say for me
yeah you're right i can't pull out no
wallets no cell phones nothing
my hands are about the dog the
the the robot might
actually not be racist it might be
program names
it might be programmed yeah exactly
exactly there's no way to win because
like
who programmed it
it's like that family guy bit you ever
see that family guy bit it's like one of
the old ones where they're in a police
van
and um
the police van starts attacking
cleveland and starts beating the shaft
just because he's the only black dude in
there you guys ever seen that it's
hilarious
but that was like the [ __ ] ongoing
joke and it's it's all ai dude it's all
yeah why don't they start with like a
firefighter dog where it has a hose yeah
that'd be cute like something outside
straight yeah i went straight to guns
deliver my postmates
gun just fold my laundry would be
incredible it changed my life forever
all of your jerseys all my jerseys do my
jersey they could probably make way more
money off just you know getting a a
folding clothes float folding robot yeah
i mean with this tour bot we just gotta
create a tour box
yeah because everyone got a room but now
we just need chore bots
that that's also a funny jump to
suddenly get it to start folding laundry
with it's what opposable thumbs come on
guys i think back to the postmates or
the firefighter dog with a little bit
more spatula hands mr wonderful with
love
a burger flipper dog
yeah
purpose
that flipping burgers are fully washed
like a firefighter dog hold your burgers
clapping
your wife come to the room honey will
you please bat my titties around i'm
[ __ ] busy [ __ ]
get the chorebot that's it
honey did he please plop my titties
commercial was written by women four
women
[Laughter]
oh man that's so stupid you guys see um
i just watched this recent advice video
that had come out too
[ __ ] is this
chorebot oh this is a fully laundry bomb
see
i feel way more comfortable and way less
racing you need that big thing in your
[ __ ] room
oh it's for commercials i was like damn
see this is like so yeah i know you're
not like what the [ __ ] is big enough for
this [ __ ]
right
in one [ __ ] space you need an
industrial sized folding machine make it
smaller bro yeah the problem is that you
need an entire [ __ ] stadium for it
yeah what does it come out like that's
just wrinkly as [ __ ] put in a plastic
bag like a shredder oh wow
dude i need one of those urban
outfitters people to fold all my oh yeah
people do a [ __ ] fantastic job oh
there's a smaller sized one
it's a mini one dude for the folder on
the go
um you know uh at disneyland uh they
have the uh avengers campus or whatever
it's called right there is yeah at a
disneyland's california adventure
something like that i missed it it's all
right um but the point is uh they have a
spider-man that every day does a stunt
jump right and it's [ __ ] high and
then i just saw the uh the vice article
it's actually a robot oh cool they have
yeah they have a flip uh literally a
robot that they uh trained it's a
three-piece mechanism that they [ __ ]
trained to do like a flip and uh
understand when the stuff but then they
3d printed like the bodily figure and
put the spider-man costume on it so he's
literally looks like a [ __ ]
spider-man that doesn't look like it's
like tom holland 40 foot he looks like
he's like like tom holland and he just
does this crazy trick every single day
and it's a [ __ ] robot and that's a
gangster it's a robot
yeah let's make robots for that kind of
stuff you know
but once they add guns to that flipper
and their defense though usually like
these war inventions are a reaction
so it could be they're tired of they're
reacting to iron man the movie in 2008
this would be good like like suicide
bombers coming and then like you know
like you have humans there and they're
like [ __ ] what do i do but then now that
would probably be the answer to suicide
bombers where if you have non-living
things like
uh securing the premises oh i see and it
would it would uh like know that save
lives
yeah they'd be like they're just gonna
blow up a bunch of mechanical dogs
and i wonder if they could withstand
that
that's a lot of money that they're
blowing up
very true
dude where the [ __ ] is the stunt jump
you see his [ __ ] actor
dancing all over the [ __ ] place here
we go
tom holland
there you go stop jump boys
this is the reason they have a robot
yeah he didn't make it yeah
look up vice versa disney played that
video before every hour spider-man just
shoots out like that yeah any any for
real it's like it looks really good he
does like a tuck and rolling [ __ ] wow
but it's a robot it's a road he
literally goes here he [ __ ] swings up
he does the whole flip but then he also
has that a very spider-man position
while he flips and then he like
opens up as he lands it's [ __ ] crazy
so i was like this is for sure human and
then an advice dropped a video like a
week and a half ago that shows how
disney uses a robot to do that stuff and
i'll cover that on here we did we talked
about it on here um i don't think
anthony was here
i'm a loser
yes this one is this one
here comes
why do they look so like
human right fluid i don't know that's
what i'm saying it's just crazy i don't
like this [ __ ] if they can make
spider-man flip they can for sure put a
gun on the dog
what about the cirque people aren't they
gonna get pissed that they're out of a
job now that's true tell me how they
will who catches them on the other side
mattress
a matches with the tempur-pedic
it doesn't even need to be and they
don't have any fear too
that's the thing you could have them
land on boxes like jackie chan quality
control dude every time not only they're
not here but if they do mess up and they
get [ __ ] over and nobody else is
crying about it it's just like oh [ __ ]
we got to get another one sorry guys new
spider-man show today gotta fix our
robot
you know
yeah i think um you guys should get a jk
robot we should huh then we don't have
to do the show anymore
hey let's organize bring the arcade
that's the best robot we can get we're
going to play arcades you are we can
actually bring it here yeah i just gotta
set it up with clutter they can deliver
here that was the easiest way oh i can't
wait
[Music]